Speaker 1: going now from Georgia to Arizona.
Kerry Lake, who lost?
She lost.
Nothing happened other than Kerry Lake lost.
Her opponent, Katie Hobbs, got more votes
in the Arizona gubernatorial election on November
8th.
Kerry Lake was recently at Trump's house in
Mar a Lago, and now all of a sudden, she says
she's going to try to overturn the election
results.
You know, we I don't know that I can say that
we were joking around, but we certainly talked
about how it seems very clear that the new
strategy and it's not even really a strategy
because it hasn't worked at all.
It's more of like a last ditch effort tactic.
The new thing we're going to see from these
Republicans is when they lose, they will say
that it's rigged and then they will try to
overturn the election and they will continue
putting out these imaginary milestones.
Oh, well, we're getting very close to submitting
affidavits.
All right.
I mean, affidavits aren't evidence.
Strictly speaking, they can be considered,
but affidavits are not evidence of wrongdoing.
Well, very soon a court is going to hear our
case.
Mike Pillow has been talking about that for
two years.
We're moving for decertification.
We heard that one from Steve Bannon many times.
Is there such a process as decertification?
No, but we're moving towards decertification.
And by the way, keep donating.
Keep donating to me.
Donate to Trump.
Donate to everybody.
Okay.
So here's a clip of Kerry like Kerry, like
lost.
She had this pompous arrogance going into
the election.
I will be the next governor of Arizona.
More people voted for her opponent.
When things go right, the person who gets
more votes wins.
Kerry like doesn't like that.
It looked like she was getting ready to move
on.
Now she says she's assembling evidence and
she's going to run some kind of campaign to
overturn the election.
Speaker 3: Sari, to remedy this assault on
our democracy, this isn't about Republicans
or Democrats.
This is about our sacred right to vote.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
What's funny is, as much as they claim it's
not about Republicans or Democrats.
They only claim that this fraudulent stuff
took place when a Democrat has defeated a
Republican.
So.
So find me a case where you tried to overturn
an election in which a Republican defeated
a Democrat.
Find me one example.
Speaker 3: A right that many voters were sadly
deprived of on November 8th.
Tens of thousands of you have reached out
pleading with me to fight this fight.
Speaker 1: Is that even true?
Tens of thousands, I'm sure.
Thousands, but tens of thousands reached out
to assured.
Speaker 3: I will, because if we give up now,
we will no longer have a country.
Attorneys are working diligently to gather
information.
Sure, whistleblowers are coming forward and
the curtain is being lifted.
Whether done accidentally or intentionally,
it is clear that this election was a debacle
that destroyed any trust in our elections.
Speaker 1: What she means is I lost.
Speaker 3: Arizonans who choose to make their
voice heard on Election Day.
Should not be disenfranchized or punished
for choosing to vote in person.
Speaker 1: Now, what she's referring to is
that for a little while, a few tabulators
in Maricopa County didn't work.
That.
That's what she's talking about.
Speaker 3: Yet they were.
I want you to know, Arizona.
I will continue fighting until we restore
confidence and faith in our elections.
Speaker 1: You know, I'm pretty confident
and and I have faith in what happened.
The candidate who got more votes, Katie Hobbs,
is going to be the next governor of Arizona.
And all of the evidence points to the voters
of Arizona wanted Katie Hobbs to be the governor.
They can recount it over and over.
They can do these audits.
And remember, they call for an audit.
The audit is done and then they go, no, that
was the wrong type of audit.
They only looked at a recount of the ballots
without evaluating whether the ballots were
ballot.
The ballots were valid.
It's the wrong type of audit.
Well, you know, they didn't look at whether
there were barbecue sauce stains from a type
of barbecue sauce common in Missouri.
You shouldn't have Missouri barbecue sauce
on Arizona ballots.
It just doesn't make sense.
Clearly, there was some kind of fraud.
What about bamboo fibers?
What about a pictures of koala bears tucked
into the ballots?
It's all varies.
You will never satisfy them that the process
has been completed the way they want.
And Luke Beasley, our correspondent who was
recently at a Trump rally for us in I believe
he went to the Pennsylvania one.
They blend together.
I believe he was in Latrobe, Pennsylvania.
Luke Or was it North Carolina?
Doesn't matter.
Luke interviewed folks where they said, Oh,
there was all this fraud.
Luke said, Yeah, but there's no actual evidence.
And they did the audit.
They go down it, and now that wasn't really
an audit in the way we want it.
And what they mean is it wasn't an audit that
overturned the election so that the Republican
won.
It's so completely predictable.
Thankfully, it's over.
I mean, Katie Hobbs won.
She will be the governor.
Nothing is getting overturned, period.
And the problem now becomes this is standard
operating procedure for Republicans.
They have now adopted this.
We don't like the results.
We say it was rigged.
We say it's just not believable that Katie
Hobbs won because she has fewer Facebook followers.
It's similar to it's not believable.
Biden won because his livestreams didn't get
a lot of viewers or his rallies didn't have
huge crowds.
This is the new refrain.
And unfortunately, you know, after 2020, we
wondered, is this ending with 2020?
No.
It extended to the special elections in 2021,
in January in Georgia.
It extended to the midterm elections a couple
of weeks ago in 2022.
And it seems pretty clear that this is going
to be the narrative that continues.
If we lost, it was rigged with all of the
exact same statements.
It's extraordinarily dangerous, and so far
it hasn't flipped any races for them.
Imagine for a second that this story about
fraud and lawsuits and recounts and barbecue
sauce on ballots and all this stuff, imagine
it actually flips an election for them at
some point.
They will never stop using it if that's the
case.
That's why it's really important that we ensure
they aren't actually able to steal an election
by claiming fraud and using these tactics.
The David Pakman Show is an audience supported
program.
We depend on you to do what we do.
We exist to the extent that people want us
to exist and allow us to exist.
And you can sign up for a membership at join
pacman dot com.
It's really cheap.
We do an extra show every single day for our
members.
Speaker 2: A bonus show where you want to
make money.
Yeah.
Everybody else that makes money to fund themselves
is back.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's called the bonus show.
As Alex Jones has acknowledged, we also do
a commercial free audio and video stream every
single day.
We do members only town halls and I would
love for you to sign up at join Packman dot
com you can use the coupon code 24 starts
now to get a sizable discount.